what's the deal with airplane peanuts
check any native american's car you
always find gin and
femurs or something you know they love
they keep the dead with them a lot of
times i almost
knocked this unfortunately almost
knocked this young lady up that was from
south dakota
and she lived on a reservation yeah and
she like threatened to have the baby
damn how old were you 37
this year it was this year
and she wouldn't even be
cool she wouldn't she's threatened to
have the baby dude and i just met her at
a motel
and she threatened to have a baby man
and so that's
yeah and then i met her in person in a
motel only hours later
wow and uh down like that huh yeah
oh jeez and it was definitely so i don't
recommend that kind of stuff i don't
recommend
making love to people off of snapchat
this south dakota dude this was in no
this is in different cities she was out
of
she was you know out of there whatever
how did you talk to her out of it how
did you talk
she came out uh she just said
immediately she's like if i have this
baby i'm like
what she's like yeah i'm having it oh we
locked a fit we locked this
big girl in our town we like this big
girl one time we eat some acid
and we locked this big girl into a room
at this party and uh
and we kept going in there with [ __ ]
pots of [ __ ] warm water [ __ ]
pouring it on i feel bad
i feel horrible dude i didn't look we
were kids and we're on
acid dude
and then bro you can't tell me this
though when i'm straight you gotta tell
me how mushrooms you blocked the girl
i just remembered how old were you i
just remembered it for you
probably 16. that's terrible i know but
here's the thing
let's say i was 14 that way it makes it
sound nice
but look she raped no she ate acid with
us
bruh she ate acid with us dude and what
happened was
and we kept going in the room with like
these pots of warm i don't know why we
had the pots of
water because i think we just were
[ __ ] up dude
and we would like pour a little on her
but not like torches
she wasn't in a cage or not she was just
you know free range
in this room right but i think she was
scared to come out
and one time we went in bro we heard
this loud sound and we went in
and she she had ran against one of the
walls so hard
had [ __ ] moved the entire wall in
this house dude
huge girl about 240 pounds beautiful
girl too
the most beautiful biggest girl that
i've ever known
oh my god uh beautiful girl beautiful
hair beautiful face
lord just large and beautiful but she
[ __ ] got lifted bro and uh
dude i remember this
yeah now i feel bad about what we did
with that bigger girl bro you can't you
can't
you know but we didn't do it because she
was big we just did it she just wanted
to she just got [ __ ] up and she
couldn't get out the room you know you
think there's more porn stars or murders
in the world
i think murders you know i actually know
a guy
i shouldn't say this on here but i'm not
going to say names but i know a guy who
killed someone
and he said and this isn't me saying
this dude i wouldn't do something like
this
but he said that it [ __ ] feels good
and he did say that do you know how he
murdered him
huh do you know how he murdered him i
don't know anything else man i used to
be in like powerlifting and everything
dude i used to be jacked back in the day
really
i was an animal dude i was [ __ ] we
were on them
protein powder under my eyes steroids on
steroids for a while when i was younger
really yeah you weren't testosterone
something
yeah you decided to run a stack just to
get jack
yeah it was like a southern stack it was
like testosterone and like uh
crisco or something great gravy [ __ ]
test and gravy d-ball and [ __ ] fried
dude i was so jacked at one point i
couldn't uh use q-tips in my ears
because i couldn't get my
really yeah is there pictures online of
this i don't know there might be man
[ __ ] find that chin
it might be uh you were just doing it
just for just
to try it out or what i mean if you want
to really know when i really think back
on what i was doing
yeah i'd love that i was just how old
were you first of all
yeah i was let me see 17 or 18.
nope it was after that that's when i got
involved in this damn cult
what the [ __ ] is that a real cold yeah
are you not on set there that's out in
reseda dude what are you doing huh
why are you doing looking for the lord
brother what do you think i was doing
same thing you probably were but um hey
man
what are you yeah bro whatever dude
you never hung around black people
things happen bruh no bro it looks like
you're in like
africa there yeah one of the abilities
of santa clarita and you were just uh
trying to blend in just an adult yeah
dude it's uh
rural it gets pretty rural out there
oh dude long enough bro long enough to
catch the sweats
you know long enough to put a warp zone
in your spirit
i was out there dude eating [ __ ]
dolphin dandruff doing dope
out there boy playing color me mine with
my own body
living out there boy making pottery out
of my dick
but i'll tell you this man um what were
we talking about oh steroids
before you wearing a coat yeah man i'm
doing dick pottery dude
that's the dark hearts bro i've been and
i've been in the dark art there's some
dark places
doing yeah i'm telling jokes jesus
christ
and yeah and then telling people when
you go back home and they've never seen
you they've never heard of you
they think you're gay they're just like
you won't like they're like you keep
flying home you don't have any money and
you're not bringing a girl home
you have these jokes yeah you're hiding
from something you know
just come out i remember my stepdad is
yelling at me in the yard one time told
you to come out yeah i was like i'm not
[ __ ] gay bro
i'm just not flying some girl home that
i just met
you know just to prove to you i can't
catch you i thought you could catch it a
lie
the worst has got to be if someone says
you're gay and you are but you don't
want to
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah you changed your
clothes the next day you come dressed
like in a mafia outfit or something like
something to totally
take him hot off the trail you know
putting out two podcasts three podcasts
a week he does that many a week
joe's [ __ ] man joe's got this game
locked
down how's he to talk to his uh he just
started kind of like we'll give me a
little bit more face time you know
he's great he's great you see he doesn't
believe in jesus christ does he
i don't think so yeah but that's fine
you know i don't think he does yeah he
might not believe in jesus christ but
i mean i think he believes and i'm
drinking out of his mug right here look
i believe i think he believes in a
higher power
i mean he's done dmt so he's spoken to
the aliens but dan you fought dude like
if somebody
top ten dude i could not i just don't
think i could fight man i remember one
kid attacked me once in school it didn't
go really well i got attacked by a bunch
of dogs
dogs that's a different animal yeah but
literally literally
literally yeah like how do you [ __ ] with
a dog two of them came back and attacked
me on my birthday again a year later
uh on your birthday swear to god when
they come back they came back like it's
this fool's birthday let's you take any
bites
oh yeah i took a call bites went to the
hospital it's my birthday i remember i
was 11 years old and then at 12 years
old two of them came back and got me
again
like they knew that's what i'm saying
man animals are but i also remember
because where i'm from if you see two
mentals hug and you call the cops on
them
and that was a rule when i was young and
that's true dude
that's true if you see two middles
hugging you call the cops immediately
because
once two mentals don't make a non-mental
you know rarely do they and it's a risk
and it's a
it's high risk low reward that's what
they call that
i think i had a little bit of that poor
white anger you know
the same type of just you know nobody
gives a [ __ ] about poor white people in
america it seems like you know except
for poor white people
so you know i had a little bit of that
angst
you know i knew dude i mean you know i
grew up around some [ __ ] real crazy
poor white people
you know the dude know all if they had a
dude in our town no arms
used to [ __ ] fight everybody you know
that dude you know i'm saying he'd get
you in that lurch he would catch you
with his between his chin and his chest
he would [ __ ] snack you like a snake
we were talking about this dude
his boy gert was his name and he would
just get you like that bruh
and he'd choke you down he had no no
arms at all and he'd fight anybody dude
and he would choke you he would show if
you went to punch him how would he block
oh bro he spin out of it he'd spin he
duck he dodged
the dude had [ __ ] i mean he just and
while he catch your hand with his neck
huh would he catch you oh he would just
lurch at you and bro the
thing is he was like oh you know what if
he hits you with that shoulder you're
going down
yeah part of it but the big move was
that choke he would get he would
catch you like this where would he catch
you your hand and your neck
he would catch you neck to neck
that's [ __ ] crazy once he got you
neck to neck girt you
but this whole family the whole family
was [ __ ] he could choke you out
psychos bro brother had sharpened half
of his teeth on one side of his mouth
dude
these people would [ __ ] you up one of
the kids was in a wheelchair or just
they never told him to walk i think i
don't even think he was crippled they
just never taught him to walk
and so the other brother would carry him
on his back everywhere like a backpack
dude
and didn't even give a [ __ ] maybe it's
good these people are
are away from society an entire family
no shirts bro
whole family zero shots nobody those
people don't wear shirts
not the girl didn't have shirts either
they had one girl in the family what was
her name
jessica she was normal
she was you know she was pretty nice she
i thought she was a sweet girl for as
tough as you know
everything that had gone on down there
and they used to put a board over the
sink at night and one of them would
sleep over the sinks they had 11
children
i mean the little i mean the house on no
joke was two two of these
studios you know and they had 11 kids in
there
but yeah it's like i grew up in in that
type of environment it's just like
i don't know you don't feel like anybody
gives a [ __ ] about you so i think a lot
it took a long time for that
some of that to get out of my system i
still feel it when i go around like
really rich people
who think that they know everything man
that stuff makes you mad
it was funny i was telling lee that this
morning i woke up
i mean i slept so much yesterday and
last night i [ __ ] slept hard i woke
up like a [ __ ] 4 30 in the morning
wide awake ready to [ __ ] kill money
get ready for kickboxing at night
and i did my usual [ __ ] i went over my
audition on uh the sides and i wrote it
out and i wrote my stuff for the day and
then i went and
i [ __ ] around then i want a messenger
like you ever go on facebook messenger
i want a messenger just to see because
sometimes you messages accumulating
yeah yeah you get some in there i got a
message this morning
it was like the weirdest thing it was
like fate i was telling lee when they
came in here
lee well you know in the agreement with
me all weekend and they go yeah i go hey
i got an email today from a couple
yeah i went to the facebook page i
didn't even answer them back
but the first line was you're a sham
like a scam like whatever that word is
a first a farce or something uh we went
to see you friday night and
we could visibly tell that you were on
cocaine no
oh my god there were genies they were
like drug geniuses
they had to be rogan people when i went
back to their page
they had 10 pictures of rogue and they
wanted to see rogan like in eight places
they're the ones that always ask rogan
annoying questions on the wrong like
yeah
and we're all gonna look at him like are
you [ __ ] crazy there's no better look
than when rogan gets
rogan gives you that love are you
[ __ ] crazy they just say
stupid [ __ ] to rogan to seem
intellectual and there's 200 people
behind you guys
chit-chat let's go take a like take the
picture and take a [ __ ] night yeah
so you could tell he's one of those guys
that he'll see rogan and
right away he called me a farce that i
was obviously on cocaine that there was
no way
that i was clean that my energy levels
on stage
were too high for my age for me to be on
cocaine
he said but i knew how to hide it you
weren't sniffling or wiping your nose
dog as soon as you do a lighter coke
this just starts dripping out of your
[ __ ] house
that's the first towel i could i could
look at somebody now now i can really
see
oh yeah then when i was under the
influence i couldn't see it now i can
really see it dude everybody my buddy
this one dude used to put his f he would
start to get a little do a little
dust you know but start touching his
[ __ ] bro by the end of the night if
we had a couple of bags
he'd have four fingers in his [ __ ]
ass dude he had like a
you know some of those people eat their
hair you see those videos where people
eat their hair you know
he just had like a weird tic like that
where he would just
i don't know what it was he just like
under the pants he would go in the pants
oh in his ass in his own ass
oh my god yeah i had a guy that used to
do this he would hold up him like he
would be talking to you he'd go
he was bald so he always felt like
something was landing on his head
so every eight minutes he would tell you
this and he would look at point to his
head
to tell you that look is there a bug do
you see it like type but you can
actually like he wants you to be an
investigator for him yeah do i have
anything on my head let me know it's
like
those people tell your nose is clean i
have anything on my nose yeah he would
look at me i could he didn't have to say
that
he would let's say he started snoring at
11 with me
yeah by 1 30 that would start he
wouldn't get paranoid he wouldn't drive
me crazy he wouldn't say a lot of [ __ ]
he would just tell me that he had a
spider on his head
then after two or three hours he would
start smacking his
hawk and that's when he would [ __ ]
die a laugh
but he would smack his own head be
honest joey after like the first couple
of times he asked you would you just
start like looking
above his head just like i think there's
something on your phone oh i taught you
him for days
or he's just switching shirts just
[ __ ] so then every 40 minutes
he'd have on a different colored shirt
so if you were a new person you didn't
know you'd be like what the [ __ ] man
you'd think you were tripping even
harder do we had time and i remember
bad acid would come through town and
like everybody would start
acting a certain way people would start
you know i remember one time people were
like a bunch of like kind of
you know grateful dead type of stuff
people were vests they'd have like a bad
batch of ass it would come through next
you know half the town's wearing [ __ ]
vests
you know women are gelling their hair
down i remember one time
um dude they had this one dude at this
party
and he'd apparently had taken a bunch of
ass that he put in his mouth
and for you know four bucks whatever he
would
like spit into your mouth like a hit of
acid
why would you do something like that
that's disgusting but there wasn't
anything else to do
so i'm gonna let some [ __ ] strangers
put acid in my mouth
for yeah for four bucks i could put the
ass in my mouth for free but we didn't
have it
oh you didn't have the four bucks we had
the four bucks we didn't have the asset
he had it inside of his system
and for four bucks are in his you know
he put it in his mouth
and then for four bucks he'd [ __ ]
fire it into you so next thing you know
bro we spend about 36 dollars
we're fired up dude at this dude's party
this dude i'll tell you this dude i see
mike right so this dude
used to get ice from anywhere like he
would get water and he had like a nice
freezer his family had one of those
you ever go downstairs in like some
people's house and they keep meeting
like an extra freezer
like they don't want you stealing their
meat so they put in like a special
freezer down in the basement or
the freezer has like a flat top and it's
like a door on the top and you open it
like that
and the whole thing is a freezer there's
no refrigerator you know what i'm
talking about
like a big freezer yeah yeah the old
school yeah so
these people had uh you know this dude i
see mike would get
water from different places you know
[ __ ] knit local water fancy lake mead
like pontchartrain um mississippi river
and freeze it
and then people come over and eat the
ice in the summer we'd go over there and
eat ice he'd out he had water from
everywhere
he had water from ireland france
lake powell you know what i'm saying so
we'd go by i see mike's and [ __ ] have
a piece of ice
he'd break you off with a [ __ ] chunk
of ice and everybody's sitting having
ice from other places you know it was
kind of
are you sure it just wasn't he just
didn't write it on the bottle like it
was all from his faucet oh no you could
taste it was from different places man
some of it was brackish some of the [ __ ]
was [ __ ]
you know iceland some of the ice he
might get the [ __ ] water from
different places man he went himself oh
maybe his family went i think his dad
did some kind of traveling work
you thought he brought back gallons of
[ __ ] water have you lost your goddamn
mind
but i'm telling you there's no other way
i got tricked no
there's no way he could have gotten
these flavors in this water what [ __ ]
flavors did they did this
they did remember oh i remember one time
i got stuck in a
tunnel my car broke down in a tunnel in
uh pittsburgh
and i had to defecate extremely and
that's french actually for [ __ ]
yeah yeah and i had to defecate and uh
so i got in my back seat in my car and
the only like i didn't have any choice
this was like
you know it was like something had
gotten into my body like a pink eye had
gotten into my stomach
and uh and all the [ __ ] in my body was
coming out of my body
it was that in your stomach yeah it was
like hey we need all this [ __ ] out of
here
gingivitis once in my stomach yeah
and i got diarrhea from that too yeah
really yeah yeah i know how it got down
there and i had to defecate into a
frisbee out of upside down frisbee was
all i had
be real yeah yeah and so i'm in this
tunnel there are cars whizzing by here's
the crazy thing
yeah extremely hard to poop when cars
are going by 50 60 70 miles an hour and
furious too
yeah furious like and also white people
like it was pittsburgh so it's furious
white people driving by
i can if other people some certain
ethnicities i can [ __ ] easier when
they're driving by honestly
you know like if a couple of brothers
are rolling by blasting some [ __ ]
good music i can [ __ ] blow ass all
day into a frisbee
no problem part of you know everything
is everybody's you know everybody seems
like it's more laid back
yeah yeah but angry white dudes you know
rolling by
you know six seven well they would
probably call somebody too huh
oh they weren't calling anybody i mean
the only free finger they had they were
waving it out the window
yeah they weren't using it to dial the
phone so you [ __ ] on a frisbee out of
[ __ ] in the open
now the yeah not the top part but the
bottom part a frisbee is basically a cup
basically the size oh a plate it's a
plate a plate
well a a plate is just a cup that's ways
yeah i pulled over the car i think
honestly i'd run out again just [ __ ] on
the ground why did you have to be like
yeah so it's dark [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
[ __ ] in a tunnel
you should be familiar with tunnels dude
why huh because of vietnam
because you're gonna do that [ __ ] again
right now man what's the [ __ ] bro
why are you why are you oh no dude
you're doing that nom [ __ ] again huh bro
what number you thought that i was
digging tunnels in the ho chi minh trail
and trying to attack you people
no i thought you made that the fruit
juice the pomegranate fruit juice that's
always in there
palm yeah no no dude no not palm nom
bro i don't believe in vietnam i don't
believe it and it happened
dude are you those uh they never found
the boats dude
oh right it's just like slavery they
never found the boats
what do you mean tunnels though bro so
anyway i'm in a tunnel i'm in a tunnel
and there's only two lanes going each
way there's no there's nowhere to get
out in the tunnel
like in a tunnel you know cars are
whizzing by
yeah and so i had to get in the back
seat and defecate into this frisbee
right
and um and then wait for the cops to
come
why did you call them how they call the
cops
somebody i i well somebody not somebody
i just [ __ ] in a frisbee the meat the
uh oh you ate them you're saying yeah
but uh you guys eight owls
yeah i think that's legal you probably
shouldn't say that on the podcast
well i didn't have a lot
i'll tell you this if you want to feed a
family of four you can't
just have one owl i will say that though
well if you look at what it looks like
without the feathers it looks like
i'm saying [ __ ] demon yeah you know
it's a real baiting switch i feel like
that's one of god's hidden agendas well
i was talking to someone about peacocks
about this i started talking about it on
stage
i don't know yeah that's a duck bro but
it's it says peacock that is something
else that is
right though go back up to the peacock
picture i just dropped that rabbit and
said [ __ ] it
and i stopped the car and check it out i
was like whoa that's flirting really it
sounds like
flirting oh if a bird drops a rabbit at
your feet hey [ __ ]
yeah it's ready to [ __ ] probably yeah
like you didn't love the french i love
the canadians
french canadians yeah i'll take them you
love canadians
period i love canadians period but do
you love french canadians
yes because they are canadian but french
bro
not into french and nobody is they make
great wine yeah that's not true people
go to paris every year
yeah but they leave
it's not the kind of place people are
milling around man
like i got f one of my best friends got
[ __ ] up one time and he started
talking about asian people we never even
seen any asians in our life
and he started your life knowing i guess
maybe like in a past life he might have
known some asians you know
and so he starts bringing up their names
bro and knowing him and knowing [ __ ]
about him on this mattress in this house
and i'm like [ __ ] dude you're [ __ ] up
bro i'm leaving right so
apparently i'm the kind of friend that
when your friend is at his worst
you [ __ ] leave bro because he's
talking about chinese people ah yeah
i've never met chinese no we've never
known any what is he saying
he's just saying like hey you remember
[ __ ] like sin
like you remember [ __ ] son lamb bro
he was there for us you know and all
this [ __ ] about my son
bro we don't know him dude you know he
was [ __ ] like talking about dorothy
dorothy dorothy you know we didn't know
any asians bro and i'm like i gotta get
away from where you came from when you
grew up there was no asians in that
neighborhood not when you were there now
there's probably
four yeah no we live in a small town
dude i mean i remember population
oh we probably had about 2 000 growing
up oh [ __ ]
this one dude i remember was trying to
be an elvison person he said he was an
elvis impersonator right
but he was just a [ __ ] alcoholic you
know what i'm saying like we don't need
any elvis bro
you know we got 2 000 people we need
[ __ ] gas money
and we need drugs yeah we need ideas
give us some [ __ ] ideas those [ __ ]
elvis impersonators
are paying the ass they really are get a
[ __ ] light
i gotta tell you something you know i
told you okay what happened to that
[ __ ] monster
yeah it's always some [ __ ] monster
dude
bro i remember this one girl i brought
uh
we had this thing for a while if you
would this queen a chick right and
that's
if you would bring a chick home and she
would fall asleep or at her place or
your place and you'd put like a piece of
this queen over her body right what the
hell is
she asleep no it's not a big issue i
think people don't spend enough time
with
real ass animals a lot of these animals
out here [ __ ]
trained imports fake ass little
dalmatians and
yeah that's people in parks man people
do anything in a park out here you gotta
notice that out here like
i mean i'm from a park as a place to
picnic you know
maybe yeah chill out make art or
something but
frisbee yeah out here it's a lot of drug
scenes
drug people living out there yeah well
gang activity like butt sex
yeah i don't know if that's what
i had magic johnson that's what they
call it you know
people out there getting that magic
johnson
my brother my brother cried when magic
johnson announced
so he started crying he's one of his
favorite players
oh that's greater than even getting aids
from a dude is crying when another dude
gets
it so so then i just got into stand up
and i always like making people laugh
like i used to do a similar thing when i
was a child
at the lunch table we'd get some kids
who were minnows or a couple
might have been minnows and a couple
kids that were well you know when we get
there and sit i'm gonna
make them drink milk and then tell jokes
and do stuff and to tell one of us
just blew milk out of their face you
know
and if you get some straight up just
couple minnows boys i'm straight up saw
it off humans
you get them to do you get them to
straight up blow leche out there dumb
dude
[Laughter]
that's america right there you know what
i'm saying
and that's when i knew i was like oh i
got some kind of a gift here
you know i almost blew the throat out of
this one boy
yeah almost through the this just almost
blew the throat out of this
this one boy named tot t-o-t with his
name
kind of a bad name too to be mentally
challenged
but also easy for him to spell and
i'm not joking that's what his father
said and um easy for him to spell
backward and forward
same name todd
so that's true man was this guy's real
his name was todd
why are you still laughing at him it's
just a funny sounding name that's all
i'm saying you're right
yeah it was pretty funny i guess yeah
well you know let's talk about todd
sometimes just say t.o.t was his name
but i knew it was tot
yeah he would try to spell it out and
you know like he was tricking me
yeah so so did you do like the open
mic circuit in l.a yeah started doing
open mics here like at marty's or where
like at
uh meltdown and stuff no they had a
place over on the west side of town i
lived
i was sleeping under a buddy of mine had
a bed and i was sleeping under his bed
for 150
a month oh wow and sometimes even in his
bed sometimes
when he would be out of town or when he
would leave for work i'd climb up into
his bed dude
and i've never been heavily homosexual
but i will say this
that there's nothing really gayer than
getting into a man's warmth after he's
already left the room you know
and climbing up into his bed man you
don't even really know that much
am i still catching that hit off of his
temperature you know
it's true man you go over to somebody's
house dude you don't know that much when
they leave the room and get the
get out of their bed you get into their
bed
you never told them that though i
shouldn't make a man out of your fast
dude or it won't
you find out who's who pretty quick when
you're doing stuff like that yeah i
remember i got on a school bus one day
and the man didn't even take us to
school he just drove us around
and uh swear to god and then just drove
us back home eventually what's wrong
with it
he didn't say anything either probably
drunk and when at a certain point
dude and cocaine oh go back to that vest
story man so here's what happened
so i you know i would get i would do
some cocaine a thousand put on these
different vests
how many did you buy again i don't know
i spent too much on them but
i would probably say the
priciest one i had was probably about
210 dollars nice damn
yeah and so i would get [ __ ] up and
put these vests on and put on sunglasses
and not
no like buffalo bills [ __ ] but at least
partying by myself you know
and one time i was making a smoothie you
know because i you know i have
i got like a new i don't know what kind
of blender it is but it's pretty nice
and i was making like a nice smoothie
and i'm [ __ ] coked up i'm partying
you know i'm living high on the hog
two vests on maybe right and i thought i
thought i
heard something outside right which is
kind of weird to even think of
when you have a blender going right so i
leave out of my apartment to go in the
hallway
lock myself out with the blender going
2 30 in the morning coked up out of my
brain right now i have to go to my
landlord dude
who lives right down the hall oh no and
tell him dude i'd have to get my butt
waxed i think bro that's my thing
like i have so much hair on my butt like
i walk if i'm hooking up with a chick
i'll walk out of the room back which is
my butt it's that bad it just makes it
i'm self-conscious about it you know why
don't you uh
brazil wax it i'm just scared of that
man i met a girl and she waxes people's
balls too
yeah they call it bnb button balls it's
actually the most common practice for
men
is it i used to date a girl who
specialized in that and
she was like man 60 of my clients are
men she goes they do the b and b you
want to come in i'm like what is it she
goes
balls and butt they literally do all
that the taint then your booty hole
never again hurt i'd rather get a tattoo
on my [ __ ] face
oh it hurts so bad i'd rather get that
[ __ ] naint stamp yeah
if you have a hairy ass like if i could
braid your ass there yeah you should
probably get it removed you couldn't
brady you could gel it down though
i could just part it to the side dude i
had an uncle and he had so much hair on
his neck he would gel it down for church
because he didn't want to
um shave it off because it was his hair
and it was like a thing against god you
jumped down the sides huh oh he jealous
whole neck hair down
you might want to gel you basically got
a ducktale
ducktail hanging out the back i look
like [ __ ] man you know
but nobody expects anything out of me
that's the best thing you don't think
you show up people look you know
people ask where's the honey guy you
know that's obviously been weird
honey you look like you've been stung by
bees all the time why do i look
are you saying i'm bloated doesn't it do
i look bloated
bro it looks like you try to drink honey
right out the hive and a bunch of bees
got you bro
wait are you saying i'm swollen
you're swole for sure dude i'd be swole
too
[ __ ] 200 bees where babies sit in my
face all the time
you look like you're [ __ ] stung by a
bunch of bees dude
where do you live at bro in a comb
you gotta tighten up bro you're gonna
get diabetes dude
what the [ __ ] conversation at the store
one night
like last week some guy got found with
30 pounds of hamster bones you know
they did in my town they just busted a
man it just doesn't
right away you got to stop what you're
doing in that conversation and giggle
because nine out of 10 people wouldn't
be proud of that happening their whole
time
you know what i'm saying like they
wouldn't even mention it if somebody
comes up to them and go ah
are you from new orleans not really i'm
from texas wait a second
i gotta go you know you get to that
point most [ __ ] people would be
embarrassed to say something like that
or it would take them 10 minutes after
everybody told their story yeah
to say oh by the way there's a guy i'm
like no we were just talking it's too
late
yeah we're ready to go home and you came
out with it and i'm [ __ ] me and lee
were dying in a car like
what's he talking about hamster meat
what the [ __ ] is he talking about
and that's right yeah they busted him
man listen they got him
what if thank god
like it's like they got him no i'm glad
they got him dude 30 pound bag of
hamster one like
i mean that's because you have to
there's not as much meat there's
very little bone in a hamster but and
pam's got a hamp probably has
like a quart like an eighth of an ounce
in his chest plate bro you can't even
make a wish on their bones
you know there's nothing in there where
do you get all those hamsters from
that's well they breed them in our town
i used to work for this group they used
to sell tattooed hamsters and guinea
pigs after uh
they tattoo them yeah they used to brand
them with concerts and raids they would
say it's tattoo just to make people not
be as
sad about it but it was a brand
of what but like a heat and ink bruh for
what like what did it say
uh 311 green day anything like a
different bands that were coming to town
toadies swear to god bro
toady's acid bath uh who else
raves whatever bruh we used to truck
these hamps into the city and [ __ ]
bend them bro
we did man because there wasn't much
there wasn't much work in our town dude
you know you had to get what you can get
and they had a man that bred hamsters
and uh and then they had to do the
tattoos and they [ __ ]
met up and that was a merger that's big
business you know
and they started uh a merger
they started doing it man i got me some
300
miles in my house and [ __ ] and some
other guys like you know what man
i'm a pretty good tattoo artist
that's louisiana and that's a merger's
fault
that means someone listening to this
right now has had a hamster with like a
band label on him
buys a hamster listen if i went to a
concert do you
think i'm bringing a hamster home with
[ __ ] ac dc i don't know i'm not
no i'm about to ride i'm gonna be [ __ ]
up the whole night with this hamster mic
but when you leave
when you leave coco when you leave the
place that's when we get you bro
you get it there hey people are leaving
on ecstasy pills they're on mali you
leave
you get that [ __ ] hams you get that
warm little piece of god in their hands
they buy it every time a lot of black
people and i will say this
because this is really factual and i
spend a lot of time around
you know in the dark arts and i don't
mean that's not black people in general
that's
the dark that's voodoo that's black
matter that's everything black magic
that's the audience and i grew up in a
mixed neighborhood dude and
uh black people don't really know
they don't differentiate between indoors
and outdoors
what do you mean outdoors can be indoors
dude what do you mean outdoors can be
indoors
black person you can put them outdoors
and you put them indoors
same volume levels same speed there's no
inside voice there's no there's zero
inside there's no edit
when you go indoors well they just don't
i don't i don't believe in like a lot of
structures and
i don't know i don't want to say
woodwork but i want to say overall that
they the difference between indoors and
outdoors
when it comes to most so incredibly it's
so incredibly vaguely racist so funny
though
it's so funny they say that there's no
filters no but they say when you're poor
that's true but a lot of people who are
poor but it's a socio-economic thing so
a lot of people that are poor
a lot of times i guess have to rely on
each other like they notice [ __ ] that
that
say rich people wouldn't notice yeah
because they have to because
you you're kind of relying on your
neighbor on usually sharing a bathroom
there's a lot of stuff people are on you
they're people and it creates people
yeah and you got and you create sort of
uh this this feeling of competition
doesn't mean you can't lower your voice
when you're in the mall in the theater
right and that's just what i'm saying
right yeah
you heard yes yeah a lot of my black
friends even
do not prac yeah they don't have indoor
voices what i'm trying to say
i think i used too many words he just
closed the car opened the window and
listened to it
and the three white walked away he just
tuned in
[ __ ] yeah bro you never get to see a
good [ __ ] smackaroo
no oh not especially not on the not on
the west coast dude you never get
you see a shooting or you see a lot more
smacking
smackeroos where you're from oh down
south i saw a brother take a bite out of
a vietnamese guy once dude
he took a huge bite out of his [ __ ]
arm bro meat and everything bro ripped
it right out
the vietnamese guy was like threatening
with all this karate [ __ ] and everything
and his brother just grabbed her [ __ ]
bit right into
that's the way to do it that stops
karate all the time
because i don't care what type of karate
you got they got no defense for the bite
you know i'm saying nobody got
well what if a [ __ ] goes to bite
[ __ ] oh my god
hold on i gotta call the main jab and
[ __ ] it okay
let me put my komodo on it and they bite
you
ass dude and you remember that every
time you try to [ __ ] hug somebody and
if you got a little divot
in it you know you got a speed bump in
your [ __ ] hug
why did i let lee talk me into eating
mushrooms on a wednesday night
look at your head look at that open your
eyes bruh
you're already [ __ ] up you gave me 800
before they let me know
we're in training i told you when you go
down the [ __ ] when you join the marines
and they'll send you to miami
you know with a [ __ ] seagull no they
say you're a [ __ ] paris island debt
what marine did they put in my
weird place and it's one thing that's
unique to me is my childhood and my
perspective of it you know
yeah it it you grew up where you grew up
in i grew up in covington louisiana and
our town's famous um
lee harvey oswald went to our middle
school uh
pistol pistol pete maravich lived and
died in our town really
uh two good shooters that's the joke
that i use off of that
um but like tulane university had their
primate testing facility
in our town that's where most people
worked at right
so and in 1994 like 70 infected monkeys
got out in our town
and they literally the police came to
ymca summer camp and let the oldest kids
leave to help them look for these
monkeys right are you serious yeah
and i remember like like guys they had
guys with like
rebel flags in their truck i'm like it's
not a racial thing guys this is these
are [ __ ]
70 these are chimpanzees and macaws that
are loose around town
you know this isn't a gang that's moved
in you know
uh but i remember me and a couple of
other kids
i still remember having a wet bathing
suit on cornering a [ __ ] chimpanzee
outside of a kenny rogers roasters with
a police officer
and three other kids like you know by
this drive-through
and this [ __ ] fat
elf of a woman honking at us like we're
ruining her
you know dream shake she's buying or
whatever and her [ __ ] cornbread
what we're trying to [ __ ] save our
town from a [ __ ]
who knows what this monkey had from
planet of the apes apocalypse yeah maybe
something walter reed missed could have
been yellow fever
um what wait i really feel like i grew
up in the stray animal belt of louisiana
and they don't really have this anymore
because everybody has pets now
but they had a long time where there was
just i felt like thousands of strays
running around like joey diaz
he got bit by animals i got jumped by a
bunch of cats on my birthday once dude
i'm not even joking dude
and one of my swear to god some of them
got me on the ground
and one of them came off a [ __ ]
rooftop from next door
i swear to god i still remember a couple
of them were getting me and looking back
and seeing one come
from something in the air and uh
and they had tons of stray animals where
i was from you couldn't you'd
infuse that in everything you did
wherever you went or if you were going
to bike or play ball
and that'll make you feel like a little
[ __ ] too i mean first of all your dad's
dying
and now there's cats jumping you it's
just really
but anyway so i was like we used to pull
these bodies off of the interstate and
bury them off the highway right holy
[ __ ]
because dogs were getting hit there i
mean literally they were [ __ ] piling
up
and i remember one time we found a bunch
of nudie mags in the ground somebody
hit a bunch of you know pornography
in the dirt and i remember we got down
and
somebody then had we realized i'd never
seen any sex before right so somebody
somebody cut out all the pictures of the
actual insertion points in these
magazines there was probably 11
pornography magazines clubs some of the
older ones club
finer ones i thought actually yeah uh
penthouse
um but where the exact penis and vagina
insertion point happened in every
picture somebody cut that out
and taken it with them i guess and i
don't know if they did it because they
didn't want people to see that
or they wanted to have it all you know
but i remember this weird [ __ ] like that
and that's when i started realizing this
[ __ ] didn't happen to everybody like
for some reason god put all this weird
[ __ ] in front of me
and so those are the things that i need
to focus on and that's when i started
thinking that i became a little bit more
confident because
i know what i'm talking about i think
what do you mean like i know when i'm
like i'm explaining a place that i know
you know yeah it's not like i'm trying
to be like
oh when you started talking about where
you grew up yeah
you got more confidence you knew what
you were talking about yeah i knew what
i was talking about so that just helped
with my confidence
so now i can tell some older jokes and
bits and there's more confidence there
but now i'm also being able to just tell
new stories
and still keep that same perspective
that i had with these other
bits was there racism in covington yeah
yeah
do you have a memory where you just
bombed you know when you you're bombing
you got to dig yourself out have you
everyone where you don't get out
yeah i got two to my crazy memories one
time some dude
laughed so hard at the show he came out
of the closet to his bud he's just right
in front of him
swear to god he's just like yeah he's
like [ __ ]
literally like jarred something in his
in his stem you know
and his buddies like what the [ __ ] dude
he's right about the front you made him
laugh so hard he just admitted he's gay
one of his buddies spit
milk or spill it on not milk um beer
yeah you know
uh i'm gay yeah his buddies are like
what the [ __ ] did it was
awkward because it seemed kind of real
yeah so i mean i've had people say a lot
of stuff i feel like that guy's [ __ ]
but this guy seemed like he might have
been honest homosexual
and then the other time that i really
bombed was
um because i'm not trying to [ __ ] you
know bring anybody to the other side of
the sexual ledger
you know well oh yeah did i tell you one
time this cop wakes me up right
he goes did you did you see him do you
know where they're at i'm like what the
[ __ ] i have
no idea what's going on right he goes
somebody called in
two wolves were fighting in the street
here
right so dude i'm at an intersection of
this
dead town bro i said i lived in this
side town for a little water in high
school
fell asleep at the [ __ ] wheel right
so i'm dead asleep cop wakes me up right
he's like did you see it and i was like
what well i'm just thinking what was it
you know how did i do it was i involved
in it
who am i and he's like
talking to somebody else the other guy
who's probably just across the street
you know
and he's like two somebody called it in
two wolves fighting in the intersection
and i'm like thinking uh we don't even
have wolves in louisiana you know
so how are you really out here looking
for that but
but also but also you have a c2 running
driver who's obviously
stalled out of the stop light hey bro
yeah but he's the worst cops of all time
in the world
and they'll be like all right if you see
anything let us know when they were out
no problem officer
you like catching the walls fighting
damn drunk as [ __ ] don't start let them
get electrocuted it's all right we need
somebody to get electrocuted on this
show
i got elected when i was younger man
actually you don't save me bro
i think it's a brother save me man and i
don't know if you're out there would you
stop already
you got elected yeah
these let's come in a day early to the
fair to test the rides we didn't know
we didn't know we didn't know we were
getting kids 30 cents
get on the rides on the ones and twos
now
like a [ __ ] you look
yeah just people that are just smoking
their own dicks out there who have no
real life like you know what i'm saying
like i've met some people who
yeah they're breathing but that's it
really yeah this idea that we're all
created equals you've never met anybody
that's a genius if you say that
i've met some people that i'm like i
talked to him i go oh i'm like a monkey
yeah compared to you
dude i talked to your buddy eddie bravo
and that guy is a real
he's out there he's like a jet he's like
a deaf like a deaf jack russell almost
you know a deaf
jack russell yeah because once he gets
going you can't oh jack russell terrier
yeah you ever been around one of those
dogs you opened the car and then next
thing you know they're at the
yeah they're like sick yeah but how's he
deaf
because you can't get him back like once
he goes you can't
you know i'm saying you can't get him
back in the car
like you're sitting there honking the
horn you can't that guy's out there
you know my home you know what i'm
talking about i do know what he talked
about
but i've never heard anybody make a
description like that
jack russell terrier that is hilarious
he's extravagant dude
[Music]
you